that's it I'm tired of this I've had it
up to here there's this awful myth about
airplanes an airplane is able to fly
because of Bernoulli's principle it's
wrong and we're gonna fix it okay crazy
so let's start by debunking the wrong
explanation
what is Bernoulli's principle it's
basically conservation of energy for
fluids
you know like air or water let's break
it down
Bernoulli's principle actually tells us
a lot about moving fluids as long as
they're not doing anything too crazy
this is the energy that molecules have
to bump into things including each other
this is the gravitational energy of the
fluid relative to the earth and this is
the energy the fluid has because it's
moving the total of the three can't ever
change so if one gets bigger another one
has to get smaller it accurately
predicts a higher pressure at the bottom
of the ocean and a lower pressure at the
top of Mount Everest what does this have
to do with planes that's where the
moving part comes in if you get a fluid
like air to move it's going to have less
pressure in it which lets me do this and
this and even this the airplane myth
states something like this the shape of
the wing forces the air to move faster
over the top of the wing than the bottom
the pressure difference then lifts the
plane Falls
the shape of a wing is called an airfoil
and yes there are wings shaped like that
however the whole idea of airspeed over
and under a wing hinges on a huge
assumption that the air molecules get to
the back of the wing at the same time
which isn't necessarily true yes
sometimes Bernoulli's principle can give
a plane wing extra lift but it's nowhere
near enough to lift the plane on its own
there are also other types of wings
shaped like this or like this or even
this some plane wings don't use
Bernoulli's principle at all and the
plane still flies other planes can fly
upside-down on top of that air isn't
very well behaved to run in a wing which
is why they sometimes put these little
wing nuts on the end air turbulence
really messes up for doing this
principle bottom line Bernoulli's
principle is about energy and plane
flight isn't so then how do planes fly
smartypants conservation of momentum
first of all plane wings are not level
with the cabin say you've got a plane at
cruising altitude flying level with the
ground the wings are tilted slightly
upward in the front
it's called angle of attack as a result
the bottom of the wing is exposed to the
incoming air those air molecules smash
into the wing and bounce off that's
where conservation of momentum
comes in if you want to know how one
thing is going to affect another you
need to know two things about it how
massive it is and how fast it's going
the bigger either of those are the more
it can do momentum is just the
combination of those two factors
basically it measures how much oomph
something has back to the plane wing air
molecules have really low mass so low
that even if you have a lot of them it's
still not going to be anywhere near the
mass of the plane the only way to get
enough momentum into those little
collisions is to make the air molecules
move really fast that's best the loss of
momentum for the air molecules is in
this direction so by conservation of
momentum to gain for the wings is in
this direction any change in momentum
results in a force in that direction
which for planes we usually split into
two parts an unavoidable drag resisting
the forward motion of the plane and a
lift toward the sky as long as the angle
of attack hi-yah is relatively small the
drag should also be small and the lift
should be enough to hold the plane off
the ground you're welcome thanks for
liking this video and subscribing to the
channel please share this video with as
many people as possible
together we can kill this myth once and
for all and until next time remember
it's okay to be a little crazy
in the last video we discovered why
humans have such trouble with time
combat response time portent vos was a
little disappointed I didn't mention
twice baked bread otherwise known as
biscuits no really the word biscuit
comes from the Latin viscous which
literally means twice baked but to
respond I did originally have it written
into the video I just couldn't find a
decent and free picture of one so I
removed it at the last minute a perma
business was glad to see the channel
branching out for physics topics right
this is the science Asylum not the
physics asylum so you'd expect me to do
now in physics videos and I do
occasionally
the thing is though I'm a physicist some
physics videos require a lot less
research I've got most of it up here but
when a half time I try to venture out
from my comfort zone and do something a
little different so expect occasional
non physics videos in the future Amit
Patel suggests that I should pay money
to have some of my videos featured on
YouTube well I don't think you can pay
to be on any trending lists I'm pretty
sure that's an algorithm thing I know
you can pay to have your videos be
pre-roll ads on other videos and while I
have tried that a couple times
the amount of money you have to spend to
make it worth it is outrageous
it's just not a viable option for a
channel with a budget this small they
even did do Laura David and Nadine
David module or I'm so sorry he thinks
Wikipedia gets his facts with me that's
not entirely untrue I have edited
Wikipedia before mostly pages on special
and general relativity it's what I know
best Ramiro Rivera commented about my
door reference Thanks I worked really
hard making Swiper clone I'm glad
somebody noticed him he's after the
credits is anyone
and to everyone who suggested ideas for
a 10k sub celebration or 100th video I
am considering them really great ideas
anyway thanks for watching oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah